ليس منحوتا ولا مزخرفا بل مجرد كتله صخريه
تعرف بحجر القدر له خصوصيه ملكيه ويرتبط
بالعديد من الاساطير لا يمكن ان تتم مراسم
التتويج الملكي دون وجوده يعتقد انه
استخدم في تنصيب الملوك الاسكتلنديين منذ
اوائل القرن التاسع الميلادي الى ان
استولى عليه ملك وانجلترا ادوارد الاول
عام
1296 ليتم دمجه في كرسي التتويج بناء على
طلبه ومنذ ذلك الحين ارتبط الحجر بتتويج
الملوك ومؤخرا تم نقل مكانه من قلعه
ادمبرا الى كنيسه وست مونستر ابي في لندن
لتتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث بعض الاساطير
والروايات الاسكتلنديه تقول ان الحجر
مرتبط بالنبي يعقوب الذي استخدمه كاوساده
لكنه احضر لاحقا لاسكتلندا عبر مصر
واسبانيا وايرلندا قبل الميلادي بمئات
الاعوام